[Music]
well print Harry and his gal Meaghan
Markel's steel with a bride and groom's
Thunder tomorrow on their big day well
that is not gonna be easy because
pippers wedding will be spectacular she
may not be a royal but she's definitely
getting married like man we are in
England for all the last-minute preps
with our senior news editor Jennifer
perros what's happening Jen thanks Nancy
well it's just one day before their big
wedding but Kate's little sister Pippa
and her fiance James held a rehearsal
today here at st. Mark's Church on the
angle field Estate we heard bells
ringing after the couple was done with
their rehearsal and as you can see the
roads into the estate were shut down
security is already extremely tight over
at the Middleton family estate where the
reception will be held tomorrow evening
we watched infrared cameras being set up
to make sure that no one gets too close
to their property line
the security team was already in place
as preps continue today catering trucks
arrived and flowers were delivered and
guardrails were put up all this as a
team of workers put finishing touches on
the giant reception tent guys this thing
is massive people are calling it a glass
palace it costs a reported 130 thousand
dollars just to rent for the weekend and
we've learned that Kate and William's
kids will have a role in the wedding two
year old Princess Charlotte will be a
bridesmaid and three year old Prince
George will be an attendant or as a
Brits call it a pageboy
you